make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
okay so this is not gonna be a super
lengthy video but there is this
interesting question that I have right
this interesting idea and it's not
really my original idea I mean I guess
it kind of is but it's kind of not right
so I was hit up on Twitter by habeo I
think it was have au 27 and they asked
the question how come darkside has not
invaded the dark multiverse could there
be someone stronger than himself there
now this raises a really good question
of with regards to the dark multiverse
is there a dark multiversal version of
darkside right like if there a dark
multiverse dark side and I would feel
like the answer is yes like there would
have to be my question is how would he
exist in what form would this dark
multiverse dark side exist right because
when you look at dark side in in the
main of the main DC multiverse and you
look at the nature of the dark
multiverse they almost kind of go hand
in hand the reality is is depending on
what source you're reading right if you
read like Final Crisis for example one
of the things that Grant Morrison says
is that all the time to Superman ever
fought Darkseid he wasn't fighting true
Darkseid he was fighting like some
avatar of Darkseid or something like
that you know it was never really the
true form of Darkseid and when that
happened he would just dominate Superman
right he would just be insane no they're
not that's still in continuity I don't
know I'm sure somebody similar will
contested but the nature of Darkseid in
and of himself is that he's just kind of
the representation of evil he's evil
personified is basically what he is now
you do have characters out there right
like Lucifer Morningstar different
things like that but in the main DC
Universe and I would say even including
vertigo like he represents evil in its
most pure form and the idea of Darkseid
is to essentially dominate the Wills of
all right that's why he's always hunting
for the anti-life equation to dominate
the Wills of everybody depending on how
the equations been written it's been
written in consistently over the years
but regardless it allows you to in some
form or fashion take over other people's
will and basically take away the desire
to be independent essentially and so as
a result of that he's always kind of
gone on these various campaigns and
Darkseid doesn't really care he doesn't
really care about things like love and
compassion and so on and so forth he
cares about acquiring power a really
good example of this is during the new
32 when Justice League first launched
and Superman ended up on the planet
apocalypse of Darkseid then like when he
came back he was like I heard and saw
some of the most heinous things it saw
it's a horrible horrible horrible place
right like it's a terrible place to live
that only the absolute strongest can
withstand those who are too weak they
perish right
so as a result of that you're talking
about a pretty sadistic and evil guy
right like this is a guy who sent one of
his henchmen to earth to in DC Comics
and they killed all the superheroes and
then that was it right I mean there was
a new new era of heroes who basically
came up you know who ended up rising
instead but the guy's pretty screwed up
then you look at the Dark multiverse and
the Dark multiverse is essentially the
result of every negative dream and fear
that anybody's ever experienced all the
negativity in existence whether through
dreams or conscious thought all has all
essentially given form to the Dark
multiverse now it wasn't always that way
really Scott's tonight are kind of built
on this originally with Dark Knight's
metal and then he actually added to it
with his run on Justice League
right so you had Perpetua who is
basically tasked with creating the
multiverse which she did and then she
created the world forager she created
the monitor and she created the
anti-monitor and the world forager his
job was essentially to create worlds and
those worlds that were deemed as being
unstable like for whatever reason they
just they just didn't need to exist they
would be given to Barbados in Barbados
when in turn destroy those worlds now
eventually Barbados turned on the world
forager and then just Korea created his
own multiverse more or less in the form
of the dark multiverse oh it's kind of
where that where that comes from right
all those terrible dreams and nightmares
that manifests now the reality is that
when you look at the dark multiverse it
exists in the form of essentially
twisted variations of hero's right so
like Bruce Wayne's parents die he
becomes a Green Lantern and then kills
everybody right like he becomes a murder
machine when he merges with cyborg he
becomes the Red Death when he merges
with flash all these things are really
kind of given giving birth to their
really really dark versions of Bruce
Wayne now we know that with the metal
series coming from Scott Snyder we're
gonna have like a whole host of other
things right so like we saw the evil
versions of Wonder Woman during the
events of Dark Knights metal presumably
there's evil versions of Superman as
well like every evil version of any
character that exists out there going
through fear or dreaming it exists in
the dark multiverse and so if that's the
case if the Dark multiverse is really
just the most evil versions essentially
of people since I so people fear the
most and darkside represents evil in its
most pure form then wouldn't dark side
be at home in the dark multiverse what
would that dark multiverse version of
Darkseid look like it'd be different if
Darkseid played the role if he was like
Galactus right like he does what he does
because it's a necessity he's not really
good or bad it's just the role that he
plays right that'd be different if that
were the case right but Darkseid is
constantly on the pursuit to find the
anti-life equations his regard for the
same
of life is not there that's the nature
of the conflict between himself and
highfather right - good guy even though
he's kind of a dick but like darkside
he's just evil right he's just a bad guy
and so if you have someone that evil and
that twisted in the main DC Universe
how would that version apply in the dark
multiverse maybe he's just like really
good
maybe it's like like it's the thing -
dark side fears the most is like being a
good guy dark side in the dark
multiverse like he's chill he's just
like he's a really cool dude right like
he's not not like strange or anything
right but like he's just he's just a
cool guy right you're just like hey man
like what's up and Darkseid's like
what's up bro how's your day coming
along man it's like it's pretty good you
know I got I got some things that I'm
worried about will tell me about it man
like sit down dude here have a beer tell
me about what's going on man just just
lay it on you know and and the next
thing you know you and dark side or
smoker some OG Kush and like chill and
man watching Teen Titans
maybe that's what dark dark multiverse
darkside is right I'll be honest with
you guys I would love to sit down with
like a cool version of darkside puff on
some OG Kush and watch Batman the
Animated Series man I would be I'd so be
down with that like that would be legit
like I think it'd be cool I'd be like
dark side man like what do you think
about the Joker's like I'm like the
Joker Joker is hilarious man like so
funny like I would I would definitely
anyway this see this is what happens
when I just talk about things and I
don't really plan videos out I just hit
the record button and just start
speaking I end up doing this where I
just kind of ramble on about nonsense
for like seven or eight minutes you know
what we need we need a video about like
Barbados in the dark multiverse versus
all the forces of Darkseid and
apocalypse I'm not gonna make that video
you know you should make that video
Tyler and emerging what is an imaginary
axis Tyler an imaginary axis that guy
needs to make that video Tyler go make
that video like like I want to I want to
see that video here's here's what I want
you guys to do how many guys to get on
Twitter and tag me in your tweets but I
want you guys to get on Twitter and I
want you all to go tweet to Tyler and I
want you to say comments explained says
you need to make barbados versus dark
side just tweet that just tweak that out
to him and just be like make that video
your nothing could be pretty awesome
right light Tyler's really entertaining
to watch anyway guys I've rambled on
long enough
I've gone on about
since long enough I think it's an
interesting idea but I think a dark
multiverse version of dark side is an
interesting idea right like light side I
guess is what he might be called but I
think it's a cool idea the dark
multiverse is always kind of intrigued
me right getting away from being you
know silly and goofy like in all
seriousness it's always intrigued me
whenever you think of a cure to like
that man it's like okay well this guy is
he uses fear to his benefit but like for
the most part he's a good guy right like
he's doing what he believes to be the
best thing Superman is it a lot of ways
incorruptible unless you're looking at
like injustice or something along those
lines but you look at the traditional
heroes of DC yes they're a little bit
flawed but for the most part they're
basically good guys and then you get the
dark multiverse where everything gets
turned on its head and you get the
darkest versions of these characters
right so Batman really set it all off
that's what that's what really blew up
the dark multiverse and made it so
popular but when I look at that then I
start looking at things like dark
multiverse Green Lantern's what would
dark multiverse white lanterns look like
if they would even exist at all what
would dark multiverse black lanterns
look like right like how would all that
work what would like the dark multiverse
Larfleeze what would that look like I
mean there's just all these cool little
things you know that kind of exists out
there dark multiverse Teen Titans you
know there's a lot of cool stuff that
you do that's what I've always said
I feel like Snyder in them should just
focus on the dark multiverse right like
Snyder and Greg Capullo all they do is
write dark multiverse stories right just
tales of the dark multiverse that's
that's all they give us right I mean we
do not know what the white Lantern's
would look like insofar as like using
the power of the white Lantern Sinestro
created a universe of Lobos so like okay
so that's that's that's that's that it
that's true by death we know what that
looks like we don't know what like a
dark multi were in the dark multiverse
black Lancers are pretty much the same
as they always were dark multiverse
black lantern dark side looked legit
like that was kind of nuts but yeah you
know tales from the dark multiverse
right just write a whole bunch of those
right like tons of those that's that's
what I would do it's like an entire
encyclopedia series of one shots right
like 101 shots telling those stories
forever oh that being said guys we're
gonna bring this video to an end if you
are new here to college explain make
sure you guys at the sub button to
become part of the Rob core if you guys
enjoyed this video make sure you drop a
like and I will catch you all later
peace
I want to say thank you to all of the
new patrons who have joined patreon.com
slash comics explained I want to give a
shout out to Henry young - Elias Jade
David J s Jakob H then John H Jason see
Austin s Austin H James Oh Matt in Jeff
are Joey M Stephen Z sloth-like lu-david
C John H lean and mean that guy asked
questions all the time Adam Cajun gnosis
9/16 I want to say thank you to all of
you all this list is growing all the
time leave your joining the patreon
[Music]
[Music]